wir alle erinnern uns in diesen stand
stunden in diesen tagen ganz besonders
an den berühmten satz der kanzlerin
angela merkel
wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das ja herr meier schaffen wir
das auch das
natürlich lieber weise ist die
herausforderung immens und es steht ja
durchaus im raum dass die anzahl der
flüchtlinge die 25 10 216 zu uns kommen
jetzt noch mal übertroffen wird aber ich
bin der auffassung dass wir besser
gerüstet sind als 215 zu 16 dass die
insbesondere die kommunen die ja eine
hauptlast auch zu tragen haben wenn es
um die aufnahme der ukrainischen
flüchtlinge geht um die beherbergung
beherbergung um die verpflegung aber
insbesondere dann auch um die betreuung
der kinder in den kitas und in den
schulen dass die kommunen besser
vorbereitet sind als 2015 2016 man muss
natürlich auch sehen dass die
zusammensetzung der flüchtlinge dieses
mal eine andere ist als 2015 2016 bis
dato kommen größtenteils frauen mütter
mit ihren kindern nach deutschland
weniger oder kaum alleinreisende männer
wenn dann eher ältere männer aber der
das gros der ukrainischen flüchtlinge
sind frauen die mit ihren kindern kommen
die auch häufig zu verwandten zu
bekannten reisen dort unter unterkunft
finden also die gesamtsituation jetzt
ist nicht eins zu eins vergleichbar mit
der von 2015 2016 aber natürlich ist es
und ich möchte ich gar nicht kleinreden
eine immense herausforderung für uns
alle für die gesamte gesellschaft wie
gesagt allen voran für die kommunen für
das kleinste glied in der kette aber
natürlich auch für die länder und für
den bund und beim bund bin ich der
meinung da müsste schon noch etwas
zugelegt als ein himmelreich als
engagement anbelangt darauf gehen wir
gleich und detail ein herr ostermann
haben wir im moment mehr hinweise darauf
dass wir es schaffen oder mehr hinweise
darauf dass wir es nach gut drei
kriegswochen drei flüchtlings wochen es
nicht schaffen nicht gut schaffen also
aktuell geht die tendenz dahin dass wir
es nicht gut schaffen weil der
kontrollverlust nach wie vor anhält
übrigens nicht erst aktiv sondern schon
seit 2005 10 bis zum heutigen tag und
wir müssen natürlich reagieren und zwar
vernünftig reagieren in form von
grenzkontrollen und zwar ausschließlich
zum zweck humanitäre hilfe auch
strukturiert gewährleisten zu können und
das was herr meier sagt möchte ich
unterstützen 1 ist anders als 2015 dass
die kommunalen behörden vor ort anders
ausgestattet sind das liegt aber nicht
daran dass der bund hier besonders gut
ihre hausaufgaben gemacht haben an den
kommunen sondern dass die bürgermeister
und die landräte vor ort die
infrastruktur nicht komplett abgeschafft
haben sondern stillgelegt haben wohl
wissend dass er gegebenenfalls noch was
auf sie zukommen jeder sofort nach oben
gehalten auch zu verlieren fällt aber
ich möchte das noch einmal auch von der
ampel wissen ihrer vertreterin hier
machen uns linda teuteberg sie regieren
jetzt anders als 25 10 216 wo man
kritisieren konnte das heißt sind sie
jetzt in dieser mut macht position
würden sie sich diesen satz jetzt zu
eigen machen ja sagt die ampel jetzt
auch das schaffen wir ich bin
realistisch und ich sage gerne was nötig
ist damit wir es schaffen und das ist
dass wir das zusammenbringen nämlich
heißes herz und kühlem kopf also wer mit
einem warmen herzen menschen willkommen
heißt die die unseres schutzes bedürfen
der muss deshalb den kopf nicht
ausschalten und die registrierung ist
wichtig wir müssen wissen werden unser
land kommt einerseits ist er ja völlig
einerseits ist völlig klar bei den
meisten der menschen die zu uns kommen
liegen herkunft und flucht grund auf der
hand und deshalb ist es auch richtig
dass wir diese erleichterte aufnahme
haben erstmal ohne asylverfahren aber
die identitätsfeststellung ist trotzdem
wichtig nämlich damit wir einerseits
sieht das funktioniere mich dass ja das
liegt also da müssen wir noch mehr tun
also was wir liegen zum reichen sie
reagieren ja also was berlin gemacht hat
das letzte wochenende einfach sagen wir
setzen die registrierung ausgeht nicht
das wird sich nämlich rechnen das ist
ein flaschenhals problem diejenigen die
sagen das können wir mal im mai
nachholen die verkennen die dimensionen
jetzt der der anzahl der menschen die zu
uns kommen wir müssen das gleich am
anfang machen damit wir auch zügig
wissen übrigens aber welche
bildungsangebote dirigieren ja ja ja in
wetzlar antwort also der grund wenn auch
wenn die rohner und da muss es noch
besser werden aber es ist ja auch schon
so dass der bund gerade zu diesem was
mich ärgert ist dass diese geräte und
die software nicht hinreichend vorhanden
sind aber der bund stellt das schon den
ländern zusätzliche geräte zur verfügung
er ist auf jeden fall wichtig dass wir
es erstmal eine wichtige aufgabe
annehmen berlin sieht das ja nicht so
offenbar wie man das feststellen kann
das ist wichtig damit wir wissen welche
bildungs betreuungs angebote brauchen
wir für die kinder und jugendlichen die
mutter bekommen und das jetzt noch sage
ich das müsste jedem klar geworden sein
dass wichtige aufgabe offenbar ist es
nicht bei allen klar deshalb will ich
sagen weil ich beides klar machen will
wir können das schaffen und das ist
wichtig und es sind menschen die unsere
schutzes bedürfen ja und wir müssen aber
auch die kleine minderheit auch von dies
auch gibt denn wenn wir unsere türen
hier weit aufmachen und menschen aus
gutem grund willkommen heißen gibt es
auch eine kleine minderheit von auch
kriminellen oder putins agenten die das
auch nutzen werden und die das auch gut
finden dass wir hier unkompliziert
menschen schutz bieten und im interesse
gerade der vielen flüchtlinge müssen wir
auch diese herausfischen das müssen wir
unseren sicherheitsbehörden ermöglichen
und deshalb ist die zügige verlässliche
registrierung so wichtig noch einmal
ganz kurz nachgefragt weil sie sagen das
hat noch nicht jeder kapiert also die
regierende bürgermeister von berlin
franziska giffey hat noch nicht kapiert
ihrer auffassung nach dass das richtig
wichtig ist dass das eine riesige
aufgabe ist also die sozialverwaltung in
berlin da sagen ja die polizisten und
diejenigen die in unseren
sicherheitsbehörden arbeiten die fühlen
sich da nicht unterstützt sondern die
beklagen eine ideologische amtsführung
dass die registrierung als nicht wichtig
angesehen wird dass die einfach mal
ausgesetzt wird und da ist natürlich
wichtig aber das sagen wir auch auf
bundes seite und auch unsere
sicherheitsbehörden und
bundesinnenministerium das registrieren
ist eine ganz zentrale sache und hinzu
kommt übrigens dass wir den frauen die
hier ankommen an unseren bahnhöfen dass
wir den schutz geben von denen die jetzt
die situation ausnutzen wollen